we're going to do a quick tutorial to
show you how to
program a spare or replacement ignition
key
for a chevy silverado or other gm
vehicles this one's around a 2009
and you can see this key the one on the
left is the one that's being replaced
it's pretty worn down
a lot of times these keys will work fine
in the door
but not work in the ignition and over
time
they'll all tend to wear down a lot and
not work anymore
so you could just go to your dealership
and ask them for the key code
based on your bin and get a a very
accurate new key made for your car
usually it's pretty cheap only about 30
bucks
you're going to want to check the dash
and just confirm that it has a service
theft deterrent system message so
what we're going to do is set a timer
for 10 minutes
you're going to have to do this sequence
three times for a total of about 30
minutes
and the timing needs to be pretty exact
you'll notice after 10 minutes the
security icon turns off
make sure that you wait about five to
ten seconds
in between doing each of these cycles
that's your cue to turn the car off
again and wait five to ten seconds
and start it over again and turn the car
on again
for 10 more minutes
we're going to fast forward to the last
one here
and you'll notice that the car starts
right up after just a few seconds
it's that simple
thanks for watching please be sure to
subscribe and like
you